this is a production of cornell
university
um so this is the title today reputation
spillovers and looking at consumer
response to wine appellations and the
information that's embedded in those
wine appellations
and just as as a way of background this
project is part of a large multi or even
transdisciplinary
grant from the usda called the specially
crops research initiative and i'm
involved in
a few of these with different people in
horticulture and food science
this one is called improved grape and
wine quality in a challenging
environment an eastern u.s model for
sustainability and economic fatality
and the captain of the team is tony wolf
some of you might know tony he was a
student at geneva and there is a quite a
cast of characters from this department
and from food science
some famous horticultural scientists
including ian
justine and alan
and you can see down below these are the
five
loosely related objectives
that bring together objectives that are
important to viticulturalists in this
case people in the horticulture
department food scientists and then me
as the social scientist and my
main objective in this grant is is
looking at this question of establishing
a reputation for consistent high quality
grape and wine production in the east
and these projects i've been involved
with a few of them and you tend to have
you'd write a proposal where you have
these objectives that are loosely
connected and then you go off and do
your disciplinary research and towards
the end of the project you start to sort
of find ways to bring your results back
to the same page and to to tie and
integrate these things back together
and i think we're making pretty good
progress
on that front with this grant
so
reputation and the question here one of
the questions here is how do you create
a reputation for uh for horticulture
products for horticulture firms in this
case
it's wine and wine is kind of a nice
case to think about because in the wine
industry there's both
firm reputations that can be influenced
by the terroir by the
soil the climate
it can also be influenced by what the
wine experts are writing about and
there's some fairly influential wine
expert rating agencies in the united
states
as well as
other places
other good press past vintages all have
an influence on firm reputation and then
economists also talk about
collective reputation which is the
reputation for a group of firms in a
similar geographic unit it's not always
geography that holds them together
sometimes it's part of an industry but
in in many cases a collective reputation
is for a group of firms in a in a
geographic unit and in addition to those
things that influence
firm reputation here we also see things
like the name of the ava or the press or
the wine scores for that ava and if
you're not familiar ava is the
abbreviation for an american viticulture
area which is a
which is a geographic unit that's been
identified by the the ttb which is a
sub-part of the u.s bureau of census
many of you are more familiar with these
than i am but it's a good example of a
of a well-defined geographic unit
and we think or we propose that this
collective reputation for a group of
wineries
might also be influenced by that ava
making a link to another geographic unit
somewhere else in the world that's more
established that has a better reputation
that's more famous
and we think that this having this
reputation linkage to another part of
the world
might be more important for an emerging
wine region like new york
the captain of this project is from
virginia and so virginia is another
burgeoning versioning wine district in
the united states and and there's a
question how do they develop a
reputation
so
this is this idea of reputation
spillovers tying the reputation of your
emerging wine region or established to
somewhere else in the world and are
there benefits are there economic
benefits to doing
so but like a lot of things there's laws
there's laws about how far you're
allowed to do this in in 2006 the united
states
signed an agreement
it was it was titled an agreement
between the ec and the united states
on trade in wine and it was amended in
2010
within this
you know 300 page legal document there
was
i think probably too many words that
could have condensed this so for
instance article 7 if you can bumble
your way through the
article 7 states that certain names may
be used as names of origin for wine only
to designate wines of the origin origin
indicated by such a name those listed in
annex 4 part a names equality and it
goes on and on kind of in this circular
language but there's very
strict guidelines about what information
you can put on a label okay so there are
in fact when you look at this annex 4
there's hundreds of protected eu names
that can't make their way anymore onto a
front or a back label in the united
states of a wine product okay and some
of these are kind of these reputation
spillover words you can't use those on
the front or the back
labels on wine in the united states
so so for instance
i used to live in the central coast this
is one of my favorite wines back there
and you can see that in 2006
a winery outside of santa barbara would
you might not be able to see this but
they explicitly used the word roan on
the front label you can see that and
then the same wine in 2007 that was the
last year before they
were told by the ttb to stop using these
protected names on their labels you can
see on their 07 label they actually go a
little bit farther and they use shet
enough to pop and the rhone valley on
their front label okay and in their 08
label which hasn't come out yet
won't have any of this type of words on
the front label or the back label okay
so there are these regulations
but
when we look out into the world i still
see a lot of
non-label references to these reputation
spillovers if you will okay so in the
anderson valley just a little bit west
of sonoma there is a festival every year
called the alsace varietals festival and
so it's a festival of those varietals
that come from this part of the world
the wines though are not from this part
of the world the wines come from oregon
washington there's a few new york
producers that go to this festival
there's a lot of california so they're
they're sort of borrowing the goodwill
and the reputation from this area to
advertise their wine festival and
further down
in southern california there's something
known as called the hospice tyrone which
is another wine event that again borrows
this very famous name from france and
uses it to to celebrate to promote the
wines you know this one's been happening
for 20 years this one is in its seventh
year
annual festivals so there's there are
these examples of these reputation
spillovers in the world just they're not
on labels of wine okay and so we're
curious this is all in california we're
curious if this hat also
can be used as a marketing tool
in emerging wine regions
so
our research question
we want to see how consumers real live
consumers
respond to information about reputation
spillovers and to see if when they're
exposed to this kind of information does
it influence um their demand for the
wine or the price that they're willing
to pay for the line
and if i could just have an aside this
this type of question is the type of
question i usually try to have in these
transdisciplinary big research as an
economist or someone interested in
marketing when i'm working with
horticulture people this is kind of
bringing the the research back to what
it means to
to real consumers and how do consumers
respond to
you know technology changes or how do
consumers respond to information or to
higher quality products
okay
and then in addition to this question or
as a sub question we're interested to
see if this response to wine information
about these reputation spillovers if
it's the same for all types of people
for all types of wine
and if that information affects these
people in the same way
okay we go into this thinking perhaps
that this type of information these
reputation spillovers might be more
important
in emerging wine regions and we think
that it might be more important for
people who
know something about wine
perhaps but that's that's an empirical
question
um and the approach we use and this is
an approach i've used a few times on the
last few years over in on the other side
of the quad in the basement there is a
lab for experimental economics and
decision research and perhaps some of
you have participated in the basement
i'll show you a few pictures in a minute
and we invite consumers into this lab
pay them and ask them to participate in
some sort of a consumer study
in this case we're going to ask them to
submit bids for some wine products and
then different treatments have different
information and we try to tease out the
influence of the information on their
valuation of the wines
so it's a it's a lab experiment a
consumer lab experiment we brought in
264 people to this and that's
if you can get i think because wine was
in the title of the flyer i think that
helped us in our recruitment efforts but
that's a pretty good draw so 264
non-student that's fairly important
so it's important in several ways but
not so students you know there's some
students in the room no offense but
students don't always
reveal their information sometimes
they're they're in the lab perhaps to
just get the prize money and go some of
them haven't developed a full
how do you say a full appreciation for
wine so it's hard to really
include them in the mix
and a lot of students are less than 21
years old and
and it was a lot of work getting the
permits from i'm not sure if you've ever
dealt with or read about this the state
liquor authority the sla
i think that took a couple years off the
end of my life uh trying to deal with
them and all their permits and uh so
anyways we got a permit that would allow
us to auction wines but we didn't get a
permit that allowed us to
sample wines which was nearly impossible
because it was in the middle of a work
day we ran these from noon to one
and
it's probably not productive to send
people back to the office after that
and what we did is we brought them in
and we asked them to place bids on seven
white wines so seven commercial white
wines from three different u.s regions
okay so we had three bottles of
chardonnay
one from california one from oregon and
one from virginia we had two bottles of
pinot gris one from california one from
oregon and then we had two bottles of
violet one from california and one from
virginia seven bottles
um is this where i tell you they all
have relatively we really went out of
our way to find seven bottles of wine
that had fairly simple labels they
didn't have cute animals or not a lot of
colors they really were mostly
text they were all from 2009
and every wine bottle received
at least one in most cases two wine
expert scores in the 80s and we took all
of our subjects through
like the sort of the introduction to
robert parking parker wine scores and
told them sort of what a 70s meant and
what a score in the 80s meant and the
score in the 90s
so it was a bit of work but we found
these seven bottles of wine that seemed
to fit these uh these categories so that
we felt we were on a relatively even
playing field going into this experiment
okay so they had the same information
about quality it was the same year and
the labels were
were as much as we could control they
were the same there was some discussion
whether we should put the bottles in
brown bags so as to hide some of these
nuances but in the end we thought that
might be a little weird to consumers
coming into the lab so we decided just
to leave the bottles
so that everyone could see them full
information and everybody all 264 people
saw all of this information
was this all at one time and were these
mainly cornell employees um i would say
that about 60 to 70 percent were cornell
employees
not faculty so
i guess we've made fun of students we
can make fun of faculty too there are
weird subjects
so
we don't allow cornell faculty
sometimes they sneak in but we don't let
them
come in we don't let students come in so
it was mostly staff and then we also
advertise on craigslist so we had a lot
of people from
tompkins county cortland county come in
we had that's a little more work so we
have to help them with parking so it's
not a preference but
but it's something that we did
and just to be clear we brought these
people in over the course of four weeks
so we'd run these sessions tuesday
wednesday thursday for four weeks two
two of these weeks were and it was all
during the winter break when staff
perhaps had a little more time to
participate in this study
that's a good question
and then these subjects randomly signed
themselves up to one of three treatments
there was three treatments the first
treatment there was really what we'd
call no information nothing more than
the information above my hand so they
knew where the wines were from they knew
the scores they knew what the labels
looked like they knew they were from
2009 but they didn't get any additional
information
treatment 2
got some additional information about
the american viticulture area and some
technical information about that ava
and then the third treatment got
information about the same information
about the aba and then we also
linked that ava to it another region
which was
similar in some regard to that ava but
that other region was in france okay so
in that third treatment we were trying
to make a link to a region that had a
longer a more established uh
or more famous wine region
okay so each of those seven wines in the
third treatment was linked to a specific
wine producing region in france
okay and that was the difference between
these and we replicated each treatment
four times
okay
that's that's our three treatments
four times that gave us our 12 sessions
and we had about
22 people come there's 24 chairs in the
room 24 computers and we usually filled
up about 22 of them each day
which is pretty good but again i think
it's because it had whined in the title
here's what the room looks like in the
basement of warren hall when warren hall
gets done i think it's going to look
fancier but this is i think for instance
these
privacy shields they're a little wonky
now i agree but i think when this room
gets built they'll be
a much more fancier enclosed unit
some of these experiments use sound so
there's headset there we didn't use
sound i was just up front explaining
this and you can see up front the
different lines on display and we asked
everyone to look at them and people
picked them up and
read them as they came into the room and
were randomly seated at these different
stations
and here's a close-up of what it looked
like up front where you had the seven
wines every day we randomized the order
in which we held the auctions
and then every week we had a different
uh practice item so before these people
sit down at a computer and start
submitting bids for the wines we
and it's it's a little bit complicated
they have to submit their wine uh bid on
the computer in front of them and it's a
it's like a program like many other
things where
it might not be fully intuitive the
first time so we ask them to go through
a practice auction so they see how it
works
and we always had a practice item every
day that we ran them through
i don't have time to talk about this
today but there's like a little sub
experiment going on here
i've been
i have a long interest in the the impact
economic impact of selling wine in
grocery stores and so my sub experiment
because each week i had a different uh
i had a different practice item so this
particular week i was i was selling
bread and cheese so that was sort of
sending out this message that perhaps
wine and bread and cheese were sold in
my little store in in warren hall and
then another week i'd have the wine and
then i had a bottle of vodka
and that would be the practice item and
then another week i just have a control
item i think it was just a game or
something and
surprising
that what you put here has a small
influence on the bids and more
importantly what you put here
has different bids different influence
on the different wines
and so those wines from virginia would
be the emerging region the wines from
california would be the established
region and people
this is a talk for another day but when
you have bread and cheese here that had
a positive influence on the the wines
from the lesser known regions so if you
were a winery from virginia and you were
selling that wine with bread and cheese
it had a positive impact it didn't
really have any impact on the california
wines when you had vodka up front up top
that had a slight negative
premium like a slight negative effect on
the
on the on the values for the virginia
wines
so i'm not sure exactly what to make of
that but that's
a sub
another question
so everybody saw this map
and this would be the map that treatment
1 2 and 3 would see treatment one this
is all they would see and so i would
just tell them there was two wines from
oregon there's three wines from
california there's two wines from
virginia and then we'd move into the
auctions
if you were part of treatment two you'd
see this map and then i give you more
information perhaps too much information
but i give you more information about
the specific appellations so i would i
would talk about the santiana's ava
because one of our wines came from that
i talk about the
lucia highlands which is another ava or
whatever i talk about the russian river
valley because one of our wines came
from that very specific ava i do the
same for oregon i talk about the two
ava's and i do the same for virginia i
talk about the very specific ava's and
these are all all three of these are
maps that i borrowed from the wine
institutes in those different states so
they're all ava
maps
and if you're in treatment three only in
treatment three you'd also get
information about
france okay and specifically we would
say that the three varietals the
chardonnay the onion and the pinot gris
have this historical roots in france and
we talk about alsace as being the
historical
place where pinot gris
was first grown in market and we talk
about the two sub-regions within alsace
and that would allow us to link the two
pinot gris the oregon pinot gris to the
top part of alsace and the california
pinot gris of the ho ran to the lower
part of this appalachian we'd make this
linkage
same with the chardonnays we'd make
linkages to three
parts of burgundy talk about how there's
linkages and the two venues we'd made
references to the upper and the lower
rhone valley to try to
enforce that there was this linkage
between those and if there was any
reputation spillover that we could make
that all make sense it's a good place
just i'd like to see a nod a gentle nod
okay
okay
good so if you were in treatment one
you would see seven bottles of wine you
i would be standing up front much like
this and you would have a computer that
would have the same information on your
screen that i'm showing
and this is what you'd see in treatment
one you'd see the bottle
we'd talk about the state and the
varietal and that would be it and we'd
ask you to submit a bid
that
represents the most that you'd be
willing to pay for this bottle of wine
and if you're in treatment 2 a very
similar looking
sheet but now you'd be given the
information about the ava
and this is a summary of the information
that i give about the ava and i had a
script that i stuck to very carefully
but i didn't overdo it
but it was a short script on that ada
and then i'd show this map and i'd show
on this map where that ava is
and again sticking to the script and if
you're in treatment 3
again you'd see this you'd see this
information and now we would make this
link to the lower rhone valley in in
france the same sort of technical
information
lead them to believe that these were
similar
production regions or had similar
characteristics i think in this case
the script said something about here's
santianez
down near santa barbara made the link to
the lower roman valley we made some some
reference to the weather in these two
places the limited rainfall in these two
places and sort of the marine
proximity to the ocean we'd sort of have
these type this types of information
that was technically true and now it was
a way of connecting these two
and there are other people
in the world in tasting notes that have
also made these types of connections so
it wasn't
i wasn't being completely fraudulent i
was
using information that someone else had
proposed
okay and then the incentives um i might
have told you that everyone coming into
the lab got 25 to participate and it
took them about 50 minutes by the time
they sat down and went through the the
auctions and left the room 25
i think that's fair some of my
colleagues are starting to pay more now
and that now that's not going to be good
because now i'm going to have to pay
more to keep up with
harry
and we told the subjects and this is
pretty important so we told the subjects
before we got going that for every
bottle of wine all seven bottles of wine
up front at the very end
one subject would be randomly drawn from
uh a drum so we had you know these 24
people in the room and i had a big bowl
of bingo balls at the front labeled 1-24
and at the end i draw bingo ball and
that bingo ball person
we would look at their just just the
administrators would look at their bid
and we'd also randomly draw a market
price for that bottle of wine and
and i also had a bag of chips and all
these chips had different prices for the
wines and so we draw a bingo ball we
draw a price so now i have you know
ian's bingo ball and i have a price and
so we privately go over to ian's station
and we compare his bid to the market
price
and
and here we go and if ian's bid
was more than the market price then ian
got the bottle of wine but he paid the
market price
and if he and sorry to pick on ian but
if ian's bid was less than the market
price there'd be no sale and in both
cases
ian's bingo ball stays out of the drum
for the next six
draws and it was a way to really try to
give people to set the incentive so that
they would bid an amount that really did
reflect the most that they'd be willing
to pay so they knew that that's the most
they'd be willing to pay and at the end
there's a chance that they might pay
that or they might pay something less
than that
um there was a distribution of prices on
these chips that range sort of between
five and fifteen dollars i never told
them that but i'll tell you that now
because it's all said and done they just
knew there was a bag of chips up there
that had some distribution i told them
it was a distribution around the retail
price for these wines
in truth it was perhaps a little low
because i wanted some people to be you
know when you pulled a five dollar chip
people were pretty excited because they
got a good deal
keeps them coming back
um
and that's how it was done and uh this
isn't novel this is how a lot of these
consumer experiments are done in labs
most economic departments have one or
two of these types of labs doing similar
types of experiments but
but not with wine and not with
reputation spillovers that i'm aware so
here's the data that came in so we had
an average willingness to pay across
everybody across all the wines was nine
dollars and six cents and there was a
and as you would guess there was a
distribution around this
some people had
higher bids overall some people had
lower bids overall
there's a few people who come in and
just bid
you know
two dollars on all the bottles of wine
travel makers
so i'll show you we have a way of sort
of filtering out those people but there
wasn't too many of those
those types
there was also people who had quite a
wide distribution some of the wines they
had a much higher valuation than others
so some people you can see over here
that
people aren't that familiar with
virginia wines on a scale of one to five
it was one point seven one and people
weren't very familiar with vyonier it
had a 1.84 out of five and so when that
wine came up on the auction block even
though
it is quite a nice wine if
i have some in my office if you're
curious we could
that one had a fairly low valuation
overall okay
the virginia vionia and a lot of that i
think was driven by this sort of
familiarity score so that 906 there was
quite a distribution around that
around that number
people on average were 42 years old
mostly females
married
children at home
there is a funny statistic about
the willingness to pay when you have
children at home
that goes up
it's positive you know i have a couple
of children at home so i can appreciate
that um and we did capture quite a few
of the of the you know self-acclaimed
wine um consumers so we had
these people 78 of them called
themselves the primary wine shopper in
their household
we also collect information about more
information than what i'm showing here
but we could try to collect information
about
food preferences food habits sometimes
it's interesting information to tie back
to think about the data and this is the
familiarity with the lines the
familiarity with the regions and then
this is the their average wine spending
habits so 29 of them spend less than 10
on average when they go to the store
sixty percent of them are in the ten to
fifteen dollar range and then eleven
percent or above that fifteen dollars
and you can see that the average price
here was nine dollars
and six cents and here they self-report
29 spend less but again that's
a little bit skewed because this average
has there's a lot in that average and
that
plays out in how they think about this
um
so the results some preliminary results
um we found that
relative to chardonnay the pinot gris
wines had about a 55 cent a
statistically significant premium of
about 55 cents per bottle
and that's you know that would be the
oregon and the virginia bottle uh the
i'm sorry this is the california and the
oregon pinot gris and so
it was the california that was higher
than the oregon but when you pool them
together it had a 55 premium
wines from oregon and virginia had bids
that were statistically
significant and negative about a dollar
five those wines generated a discount of
about a dollar five relative to the
wines from california
that shouldn't come as any great
surprise and then these treatment
effects that i went to great lengths to
you know set up this experiment think
about these treatments thinking that
people would have uh
when i did this the first time they're
really it was kind of sad but there
wasn't any information
treatment effects
so that was uh
i went home and sort of commiserated
bottle of wine
but actually then the next day i got up
and i thought you know that's not that's
not such a terrible finding because it
wasn't uh the fact that overall we found
that effect is kind of in line with what
we were thinking whether we knew it or
not but maybe once you pool oregon
california and virginia together you
might not see this type and in fact it
might be a confounding effect where it
was positive for some and negative for
other and overall you don't see it so
then we went back and we thought more
carefully about the
wines from oregon and virginia
and when you separate those wines from
oregon and virginia because they had
these these bids that were a dollar five
less than the ones from california we
found that
the bids for those wines when you
separate them out those bids actually
did respond to the treatments they
didn't respond to the ava treatment so
when you gave them information about
oregon virginia and then you talked
about the avas in those regions because
those regions aren't very well
established giving more information
about the region didn't do anything to
their bids but when you
told them about the avas and you told
them about how those avas are similar to
these avas in france then you found a
positive and a statistically significant
effect on that treatment 3
for those wines
so that's that to me is a
that's reassuring that's a good uh
that's a good result to me and then
perhaps uh
i think we found that was about a 60
cent premium for those wines
so so if you have a dollar five less
overall and you can get 60 cents from
that back
by having this link to france among
these 264.
and then furthermore we took the sample
the 264 people and we split it in half
according to your familiarity with wines
so this would be familiarity with either
wine regions or wine varietals and it
didn't matter which way you split it on
either of those parameters but for the
half of people that were more familiar
with wine
regions are more familiar with wine
varietals they also had a positive a
statistically significant and positive
effect on treatment three so again that
linkage to europe had
had a strong positive effect for wine
aficionados if you will and it had a
positive effect for those wines from
oregon and virginia okay and then it
even had the strongest effect
among the wine aficionados on their bids
for those wines which we think are the
are the emerging wine regions i think
if you really
enjoy wine drink a lot of wine you might
not think oregon is an emerging wine
region but i think to many of the people
and when you look at wine shops in
ithaca there's not a lot of oregon wine
available so i think it's fair to to
call these two the emerging regions
relative to to france and
california
and i always like to finish a slot uh a
talk with some implications i think it's
probably just my extension appointment
hat going on and what does this mean to
to real people what does this mean to
some of my colleagues involved in this
project and
it seems that when you draw attention to
abas for wines from emerging regions it
really
it's not it maybe isn't a good use of
your time and money if the if it's an
emerging region then the ava is probably
even more emerging and sort of dwelling
on that type of information doesn't seem
to have an impact on
although that's the information you're
allowed to put on the label it doesn't
seem to have
an effect doesn't seem to impact
consumer evaluation of those wines and
even amongst your wine aficionados that
pick up the bottle and actually read the
front and back labels it still didn't
have
when you talked about the monticello ava
in virginia it just didn't seem to have
doesn't resonate with consumers the same
way
it does when
that ava is linked to another region in
another part of the world in our case to
these well-established regions in france
okay and that that really did resonate
with subjects and so if there is some
non-label way to do this it seems to be
seems to have more
bang for your buck in in a marketing
strategy way
i think i've said this but this is uh
just sort of trying to recap the main
punch line that it's uh that's these
emerging regions and it's these
consumers that have some
wine knowledge seem to respond most to
this treatment three
i think that's where i stopped i have a
big table of
results i stuck at the end because i
didn't want to
someone told me once that's not a nice
thing to do but
so i have heaps of more results if
you're curious i'm hoping to write this
up soon
i've always got good comments from
horticulture faculty and food science
faculty so
if there's any questions or suggestions
i'm
i'm happy to and frannie told me that
people would be excited if i could stop
before 110.
i guess that's a problem
but if you have any thoughts
thank you how about chris uh just a
quick uh comment the reason you didn't
put
new york in there is to eliminate bias
by locals who might know some region in
new york or indians
yeah that's a good point i should have
said something yeah there's a home bias
effect that sometimes can go on and so
here we are in the finger lakes and i
think at one point we thought we might
have included it and then in the end
it just would be hard especially if
you're trying to submit it to some
journal and uh
and they see this home bias effect i
think we could have added it as at one
point we were thinking about adding a
fourth region
might have been washington it might have
been new york
but in the end it was this trade off the
home bias effect and then we felt that
seven wines
for people who weren't great wine
lovers to ask them to submit bids for
more than seven wines might be some
fatigue
going on in the lab too but that's a
good question it's mostly this home bias
i think the wine states in the united
states the top is california the second
is washington the third is oregon the
fourth is new york and the fifth is
virginia and so we picked one three and
five as a way to
motivate these wines and that ordering
changes a bit year to year but that's
sort of the 10-year trend
how about ian so i i think where you see
a huge impact is
if you sort of could
go past region and put a buzzword like
champagne or
cognac or armeniac or where you get into
the
the names that are specifically ringed
with a lesion
linked with a region but the name itself
is really well known right
and i guess that's illegal now as well
under the wto rules but yeah so those
macro regions it's a and it's
but it's it's careful it's a it's a very
funny
it's it's illegal to put that on the on
the labels or on your promotional
material but it's something that you're
allowed to talk about in the tasting
room it's something you're allowed to
put in your tasting notes it's something
you're allowed to name a festival after
um
you know so there's these the second
order of uh of information that that
and that's why it kind of ties itself
nicely to the this collective reputation
where so it's not necessarily something
that a firm is promoting but a group of
firms at a festival or as part of
promotion of their appellation and sort
of tying that appellation to
some other part of the world but then
you're right there's this degree of
famousness of regions and other parts of
the world and
how do people respond to those different
and we thought there might be something
because we thought that burgundy was
more famous than alsace but we didn't
find any
statistically significant difference as
to those three different regions in
france that we tied them to you're right
people were confused by the word
burgundy because california for years
sold cheap wine they called burgundy and
it's
it's
you know then there's pinot noir within
burgundy
i think most americans
kind of haven't figured
yeah
and then yeah and then at one point we
were worried if we just said this
information without our pictures you
know with that influence and so maybe
maybe it's one of these things where
there's a visual plus some text
which we were able to include in this
but
about jenny um we saw that
they averaged four meals out a week is
that normal is that high and if it's
high would that increase or like inflate
the price that you're willing to pay
because they're comparing it to
restaurants um yeah that's a good
question and this
did we put that in this list
yeah it was in the
summary so in one of i think in an
earlier model we included that as an
explanatory variable and does the number
of restaurants per week influence your
valuation of these wines thinking that
people who go out more
would spend more on wines and it wasn't
in this table which makes me think that
it fell out and it wasn't important so
we we asked them how many meals do you
eat for a week and there was a drop down
menu of between 1 and 21 and uh
yeah i was surprised to see it four but
i think you know if you eat out at uh
at school or at uh
at work
three days a week then uh then there's
your where that number is coming from it
was a bit high though to me that seemed
high i don't eat out four times a week
so
that's burger king and mcdonald's right
yeah and then there's a quality of
eating out
we might have also asked them what's
your average uh spending on a bottle of
wine what's your average spending at the
grocery store per week what's your
average
we ask them like a survey
some there's also survey fatigue i think
on this one we ask them 35 questions and
we ask more specific things
in the end we know we won't use all this
information but we collect it because
we have them trapped
in the lab
it seems to me actually the subjects
actually participate in your question
must be actually very knowledgeable
about the wines
if a subject like me have no idea so
that the apa whatever is useless to me
actually
so are there any so my question for you
actually are those how you decide to
recruit which subjects participate yeah
so that's a good question so you
recruited me actually so this
fail actually looks great
well the only way we would recruit you
is if well you wouldn't be allowed
because you're a faculty member
i have like a big bouncer at the door
because you know i have no knowledge
about it so it's all you decide actually
this guy is knowledgeable or this person
is knowledgeable okay so that's a good
question so in the flyer in the call for
subjects we were fairly specific and we
said we're looking for we're running a
wine experiment
and you have to have
purchased
and consumed white wine at least once in
the last two months or something like
that so that was the criteria for
signing up it was hard for us to check
that information at the door
but we also asked that question in the
survey and occasionally you get people
that that
when they answer that question the
survey is zero then we're we drop them
from the uh from the regression we drop
their that observation from our analysis
so we ask them how many times a week do
you drink or we ask them how often do
you drink wine
once a day
once a week once a month type of thing
and then we use that information that
also has an influence on willingness to
pay and in the regression we can you
know we can holding everything else
constant including this we can try to
tease out these treatment effects
that is a good question that's sort of
problematic and i should say if i have
one minute frannie's standing up so we
don't lose everybody in geneva before
they ask their questions oh okay
so just i think to sort of address this
you'll see that in the bigger model we
have every time i report results i have
something called the full sample which
is everybody who came in all
264 people and then we have this
restricted sample where we drop out
people who don't drink wine had bids
average bids less than three dollars
sort of these troublemakers
they were less than 21 years old but
there weren't any of those in the room
but people who didn't uh
this is sort of a way of looking at the
more focused group
so that's a good question so can we is
there anybody in geneva who has a
pressing question
i was just wondering if
as part of the study you were interested
at all in the
evaluation of wines according to the
bridal
and familiarity with um chardonnay
versus innovate versus vln
yeah so that's a good question so we
have
that's something we're going to explore
more but we we've started to tease out
and found that the the valuation of
pinot gris
was higher than chardonnay the value of
veonier was less but not statistically
significant but it was less than
chardonnay and so we're doing some of
the things i've been talking about
here i've also been doing bi-varietal
and so this is typically how economists
think about have all of this data and
today i talked about sort of the big
picture results i talked about the
results for specific types of people
more or less knowledge about wine or
more or less familiar with wine but
that's a good
sort of next step is to think about do
these treatment effects differ based on
varietals
and my guess is the general story will
will hold up but that the general story
will be stronger for pinot gris and not
as strong for vioni
but it's just trying to think about what
what story how i want to slice and dice
the data to prepare these titles these
tables which way is most effective but
that's yeah that's a very good question
it's something we're thinking about
sort of the beauty of having so many
observations is we can split the sample
in half according to these different
parameters
how about behind ian
is there any reason why you chose whites
rather than ribs i mean your initial
example was a red
right soccer base right good point um
so at one point we thought well we
didn't want to mix whites and reds and
then we had to decide whites or reds um
originally we thought we were going to
have new york in the mix and uh
we thought that if new york was in the
mix it would probably be a riesling that
would be in the mix and then they
weren't and then we just kind of got
going with whites there is there is and
i talked to tony wolf about this last
week there is a thought that we would
try to replicate this with red wines
which would be
fun if we found
you know a similar
set of results but uh
but yeah i don't i don't have a great
answer why we started with whites i
think we just kind of got going and then
we had done all this research and found
all of these
wines and uh
went with it
i would be curious that's a good point
how about uh
um so you said that there wasn't much
effect from the aba
designation i'm curious how
sort of you promote an emerging industry
while trying to maintain this quality
that's
recognized from a particular area you
know if you're getting lines from
outside
the monticello region
and a consumer sees that and says oh
this is what virginia wines taste like
it must all be garbage like this one how
do you
maintain that quality perception
without
a real like designation
yeah so i guess
i hope i understand your question
correctly but i think so we're not
advocating that you sort of abandon the
promotion and the work that goes into
developing an ava
but
in addition to that i think we think
that to sort of give a kickstart to an
emerging ava
to bring in this uh this sort of outside
information might and maybe this helps
answer your question but we found that
the value of the aba
actually was stronger than the link for
the california wines so in a in a
it's not really part of this set of
results it's sort of a second s
level of results but the
value of the ava was actually more
important for california one for all
three wines in california then was the
link to burgundy alsace or the rhone
valley
so it's again it's sort of thinking
about
you know developed wine region versus
emerging wine region the level of aba
that you're using for california would
be
generic like
napa valley not
los carneros or how specific were you so
i was fairly specific so and in fact the
bottle of wine maybe i showed you zach
mesa said the
senionez valley right on the bottle of
wine i encouraged them to read that and
then i showed them a blow up like this
on their and so i said this is the
santianez valley i showed them where it
was down near santa barbara and i did
the same thing for a pinot gris that
came from
monterey but it wasn't monterey aba it
was from
santa lucia highlands which is a fairly
small and then i did the same for the
russian river valley which again is a
you know some people might i might have
i didn't use the word sonoma i was
pretty careful i just i always said the
aba and then i said the city for which
that aba was close to so i never
actually ever said the word sonoma or
or napa in any treatment
that's a good question did you have a
question over here
assassin okay how about bill
who who buys the most you know who who's
the main consumer is it is it male
female because yet 74 of your
participants were female when they
bought 80 of the wine how does that yeah
so that was a bit uh surprising to me
too so in states where wine is uh
available in supermarkets
females buy a lot more wine than males
but in the state of new york
men buy more
wine
than women so i was a little surprised
by that but you know that might have
been a response to my call
you know these people sitting in their
office they saw the call for this
particular and they said you know do i
qualify for this
experiment um but that's not exactly an
answer to your question but it does it's
i found that you know since prohibition
stopped in this country all these states
have these different laws about who can
sell and buy and hours of distribution
all of your sort of wine demographic
information there you have this national
demographic but then each state that
does change surprisingly
consumption changes a lot by state
which maybe is surprising but it changes
quite a bit and and the people who buy
wine
surprisingly different across states
how about chris
you mentioned at the beginning that
french are becoming quite restrictive in
what they allow to be put on labels of
foreign wines
if we extrapolate new york state
okay you can't put
from roan valley or from some place in
france on your label
would it help
new york wineries to have
oh this is just like the one out of the
napa valley
yeah so that's like the interesting
question so that's like a reputation a
domestic reputation spillover and i
should back up and say that that
european agreement actually has
um
all major european countries has
restrictions on
mosul valley from germany and pages from
italy it just happens to be that france
has the most pages of
of restrictions
but that's a very good question
chris because there is a little bit of
buzz in the monticello aba they're
calling themselves the napa valley of
virginia and so you even see these
little
is anyone from virginia have you heard
that expression
um but it's not done in a sort of a
promotional effort i just hear people
using this sort of expression the first
time i heard it i was thinking huh
that's uh that's a curious domestic
reputation still over uh that wouldn't
be legal on the label either though but
that wouldn't be legal on the label um
but but again it's sort of these
non-label references or non-label
promotion uh efforts
but seriously this time
who would like to read this just like
credit card this kind of stuff oh but
if you buy a lot of wine
and every year when you have a new label
you have to submit your proof to the ttb
and they have to approve your label so
it's very regulated
so uh granny thank you very much
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu